bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat la réforme de rythme
scolaire est obligatoire depuis le mois
de septembre 2014 dans les 24000
communes françaises qui disposent d'une
école depuis le début du mois de
septembre il y a eu certains incidents
le mouvement des gilets jaunes la faire
des écoles cadenacé ou encore certaines
communes qui rechinent toujours à mettre
la réforme en place par exemple à
Marseille dans les Bouches du Run dans
le fief de Jean-Claude Godin sénateur
maire UMP malgré ces quelques incidents
dans l'ensemble la réforme est mise en
place par la plupart des communes cette
réforme qui stipule que désormais les
enfants iront à l'école 4 jours et demi
par semaine l'objectif est bien c'est
d'alléger les journées de cours de mieux
les répartir sur la semaine et de faire
en sorte que certaines heures soient
remp remplacé par des activités
périscolaires ces activités
périscolaires c'est justement ce qui
pose problème à certaines communes c'est
le financement de ces activités qui
posent problème alors certes l'État a
prévu 50 € par élève et par an par
commune mais cela risque d'être
largement insuffisant la MF
l'association des mairres de France
estime que cette réforme coûte au moins
150 € par an et par enfant et de
nombreuses communes vont jusqu'à au
moins 400 € par an ce qui les empêche de
faire un certain nombre d'autres projets
ce qui reporte certains autres projets
c'est donc un objet d'inquiétude pour de
nombreux élus locaux et c'est très
important à l'approche des élections
sénatoriales du 28 septembre prochain
puisque ces élus locaux seront appelés
aux urnes pour renouveler la moitié de
la Haute Assemblée et que certainement
cette réforme et bien c'est encore un
caillou dans la chaussure de la gauche
tout de suite retour à des auditions qui
ont été menées par le Sénat cette année
sur cette réforme des rythmes scolaires
avec avec notamment l'audition de
l'Association des maires de ville
moyenne pourquoi la ville d'aras s'est
engagée ça vous
intéresse bien alors effectivement à la
je dirais on on avait mis en place une
une analyse des besoins sociaux sur la
ville donc avant que ne cette réforme ne
soit annoncée et cette analyse nous
avait quand même révélé des chiffres
alarmants qui nous
ont fait je
dirais partir dans cette mise en place
de la réforme pour pour l'année 2013
donc nous y avons travaillé les services
et les et les élus donc d' ce binô entre
entre une élu et et un directeur un
directeur général adjoint qui a été très
très précieux parce que j'avais pas de
direction à l'époque de directrice
maintenant j'ai une directrice quand
même bien donc comme vous le savez
l'éducation constitue une priorité
majeure elle est encore plus chaque jour
dans un contexte de renforcement des
inégalités et de la crise sociale euh
l'égalité des chances pour l'accès au
savoir la formation des citoyens tout ça
c'était je dirais le développement des
compétences favorisant favorisant
l'emploi nous ont ont été les objectifs
clés pour pour cette mise en place donc
euh un projet ambitieux hein et qui qui
allait de de de fait avec le le projet
éducatif territorial euh
mais ça ça s'inscrit dans dans une
longévité hein dans une c'est c'est
c'est pas c'est pas de l'immédiat on
sait très bien que cette réforme elle va
pas on va pas on va pas en porter les
fruits tout de suite bien évidemment
c'est un travail de longue haleine donc
il fallait faire de de l'éducation
àveecteur de de développement du
territoire d'arass et ça demande du
temps de la stabilité hein dans cette
mise en place et la puniaacité et c'est
je crois ce dont nous avons fait preuve
avec Monsieur Frédéric leurque qui est
le maire d'aras et qui a vraiment pris
cette cette ligne de conduite ça ça a
été la la priorité dès qu'il a pris la
succession de Monsieur van leurenberg
d'ailleurs sénateur voilà
euh donc la réforme va dans va dans ce
sens hein de de retrouver une égalité
une une une une possibilité de de
l'apprentissage pour pour chaque enfant
et et nous y avons travaillé donc je
sais pas si Monsieur monsieur bayul
veut je vais peut-être continuer la
ville d'aras c'est 3300 élèves dans le
public 26 écoles maternelles
élémentaires avec de deux groupes
scolaires de deux écoles primaires et
nous avons également d'ailleurs six
écoles privées avec 1400 près de 1500
enfants euh mais bon eu ne sont pas
assujettis à appliquer cette réforme
euh nous avons donc au vu du du constat
de de de baisse de de niveau euh euh et
sur les chiffres dont je vous ai
parlé 60 élèves en situation de
décrochage tous les ans c'est énorme
c'est énorme et et c'est euh je vous dis
encore une fois ces chiffres de de de
l'analyse des besoins sociaux qui sont
qui sont ressortis 22
% d'élèves qui ne maîtrise pas les
savoirs de base lire écrire compté à
l'entrée en au collège et dans les dans
les dans les usus il y a plus de 40 %
d'enfants voyez haras se donne donne
l'illusion d'une très belle ville plutôt
bon mais non on a autant dans le
centre-ville d'ailleurs puisque la la
ville est partagée en trois quartiers
hein et et autant dans le centre-ville
que dans les les écoles plus en en
apparence en difficulté nous avons des
des enfants qui sont qui sont vraiment
en grande détresses
d'apprentissage beaucoup beaucoup bien
sûr issus de de des origines social du
du milieu social mais pas que donc ben
la réforme c'était euh que les les
enfants scolarisés arrivent au CM2 à 5
ans on va dire à pouvoir justement
maîtriser tous ces savoirs dont que je
viens d'évoquer
donc on a pris on a appliqué une méthode
bien évidemment hein je vais essayer de
donc ça a été quand même une révolution
au niveau de la collectivité bien
évidemment parce que cette mise en place
donc c'est c'est faite à la rentrée de
2013 nous avons opté pour le mercredi
matin nous avons opté
pour 3/4 d'heure le soir de pour les
élémentaires nous avons choisi deux deux
scénarios un scénario pour les écoles
maternelles et donc
une des des fameux tap euh à partir de
13h15 jusqu'à 14h et pour les écoles
élémentaires de
15h 15 à 16h alors pourquoi ce choix
c'est ça s'est fait en grande
concertation ça je tiens à le dire avec
l'Éducation nationale avec l'inspectrice
de circonscription mais également le
daen du pas decalais qui nous a fait
certaines recommandations donc on a dû
je dirais aller porter la bonne parole
aux parents aux enseignants aux
associations parce qu'elles sont elles
se sont forcément aussi il y a eu une
répercussion sur toutes ces toutes ces
instances donc la la le choix de des des
petits c'est tout simplement parce que
les les maternelles bien sûr le temps de
sieste est privilégié bien évidemment et
pour les les petites les les moyennes et
grandes sections euh ça leur permettait
dans un temps ludique de et avant de
reprendre le les cours de de de pouvoir
se poser mais en en ayant je dis cet
éveil au travers des des choix que l'on
a que l'on a proposé dans les ateliers
donc ça ça a été alors pour les
élémentaires ça se fait en fin de
journée et là ça c'est on a eu je dirais
ça a été très consensuel les maternelles
moins parce que parce que on avait pas
l'adhésion des enseignants ça leur
plaisait pas trop qu'on fasse les tap à
ce moment-là de la journée donc on a eu
des je dirais des des des d'école plus
de 300 heures de concertation ça a été
énorme ça a été un travail vraiment de
tous les services des élus dans dans
leur ensemble et de l'inspection
académique qui nous accompagnait pour je
vous dis pouvoir justifier de ces choix
que nous avons fait et ça pas été une
mince affaire quand même c'était assez
sportif et il faut être comme je le dis
à Monsieur Bayol il faut être en bonne
santé parce qu'on a eu des conseils
d'école allez 23h le soir bon je sais
bien qu'ici dans dans ces instances il y
a pas TROP d'heure mais bon et et
effectivement on a on a eu on a fini on
a trouvé le le le bon
tempo on a fini par avoir l'implication
des parents qui se sont mobilisés autour
de de de ces choix et bon après il y
avait des réticences bien évidemment à
une période en plus où le conseil
municipale dans son ensemble était
également favorable he on n' pas eu de
bon on en a eu un petit peu à la rentrée
de septembre c'est un petit peu sur le B
sur le le tapis on va dire hein pour une
période qui qui se veut un petit peu
délicate évidemment donc voyez on a
essayé de de de pas rentrer dans ce
jeulà on a gardé notre ligne de conduite
et et avec une volonté tellement forte
que qu'aujourd'hui on peut dire euh j'ai
j'ai pas suivi tout mon tout mon fil
rouge he monsieur Bayol s'il veut
rajouter quelque chose il le fera voilà
et puis on pourra compléter par vos
questions mais on a euh
on a aujourd'hui on peut dire alors la
rentrée scolaire s'est
faite dans de bonnes
conditions la première semaine a été un
peu compliquée puisque nous avions nous
avions tablé sur 50 % d'enfants qui
assisteraiit au au fameux tap et en fait
très vite on en a eu 70 % donc on avait
anticipé sur des recrutements sur une
réserve de recrutement hein de puisqu'on
a on a on a mis en place quatre ateliers
les langues le sport la la culture et
puis les sciences et donc ça a été
vraiment cette mise en place complexe
mais qui nous a
demandé et et on y a mis les moyens on y
a mis les moyens si tout à l'heure vous
avez des questions à nous poser
là-dessus on vous on on vous répondra
mais ça nous a quand même demandé une
redistribution des des cartes
et à ce jour les ateliers fonctionnent
bien les enfants sont quand même
toujours un peu fatigués d'après les
parents ou même d'après certains
enseignants globalement ils sont ils
sont ravis hein de ces ces ateliers je
parle des enfants et c'est quand même de
toute façon bien bien là qu'on veut là
où on veut en venir c'est l'intérêt de
l'enfant le le bon équilibre d'une
journée de de petit de petit écolier
et beaucoup de succès pour les ateliers
bien évidemment et c'est je dirais c'est
c'est tout à fait logique en revanche on
a mis en place également avec euh des
conventions avec l'Université d'Artois
donc à Haras des conventions et les
enfants peuvent bénéficier de de d'un
éveil non pas d'un apprentissage on est
bien d'accord on est on se substitue pas
aux enseignants un éveil à
la à à la au chinois et ça ça plaît
énormément à nos petits on a la chance
d'avoir une l'Institut confutius à aras
et on a donc effectivement essayé de de
d'utiliser ces ces richesses en local et
l'université a joué le jeu on a fait des
aménagements pour les étudiants et donc
ils interviennent dans dans les classes
hein par roulement bien
sûr l'espagnol plaît beaucoup aussi
moins l'anglais parce qu'en fait les
enfants on font de l'anglais à l'école
et ça les a ça les attire moins mais
vous voyez on a on a vraiment euh eu à
cœur de de de leur donner tout un un
éventail de de de choses riches
nouvelles je vous dis encore une fois
avec la chance sur haras d'avoir des du
potentiel hein on a on a un partenariat
avec Versailles on a eu les carrosses de
Versailles pendant 18 mois et là aussi
ce sont des des et le partenariat se
continue on va faire une vidéo une
visonférence avec le le château de
Versailles pendant l'tap donc c'est
aussi là une une rich richae le sport
avec euh tout tout ce que ça peut
comporter de découverte de certains
sports que les enfants ne pratiquent pas
toujours et puis et puis le nous avons
aussi une cité scientifique une usine
qui a été réhabilitée il y a quelques
années en cité scientifique et là aussi
on fait des des partenariats donc voilà
on a on a vraiment eu à cœur que ces
aménagements de temps périscolair soit
euh vraiment une possibilité pour les
enfants de toucher à plein de plein de
choses euh
l'éveil comme comme on l'a comme on l'a
imaginé il est l'inquiétude des
enseignants c'était je l'ai entendu un
petit peu tout à l'heure parce que je
regarde j'ai écouté un petit peu la fin
de des interventions c'est vrai que
l'inquiétude des des enseignants c'est
occuper leur classe être un peu rentrer
un petit peu dans dans leur maison hein
ils sont chez eux donc on a essayé là
aussi de trouver des des des bons
compromis on a essayé d'utiliser des
endroit euh pour pas toujours je dirais
entre guillemets les envahir et puis et
puis l'inquiétude des parents de de de
voir que le leurs enfants allaient être
allent découvrir des nouvelles têtes bon
c'est vrai que ça ça a été une des
grosses
inquiétudes la sécurité bien évidemment
parce que encore une fois je vous le
disais tout à l'heure on s'est retrouvé
très vite avec plus de 60 % dans
certains endroits même 85 % dans
certaines écoles de de de jeunes de
d'enfants qui participaient au tap donc
il a fallu être très réactif et on a
fait un organigramme et peut-être que
Monsieur Bayol si je lui laisse quelques
minutes parce que le temps est compté
pourra vous en parler mais
l'organigramme du service éducation de
la ville a été complètement bouleversé
enrichi et et et c'est bien sûr une
volonté politique au sens noble du terme
qu'on a voulu mettre sur ce sur ce cette
action et aujourd'hui je vous dis encore
une fois il y aura à revoir des des
petits
ajustements échanger avec le daen avec
l'Inspection Académique pour apporter
des améliorations mais néanmoins les
choses se passent bien il y a toujours
une école ou deux où c'est un petit peu
plus difficile mais vous savez j'ai eu
l'occasion d'avoir d'être invité il y a
quelques mois à Paris par le la Gazette
des communes et nous avons également
échangé avec des communes qui s'étaient
lancé dans la réforme d'autres communes
qui attendaient notre témoignage et
c'est vrai que bon on n pas on a
toujours quelques quelques réticences
mais globalement euh pour haras
peut-être parce que nous avons la chance
comme V moyenne d'avoir une richesse sur
le le territoire c'est pas forcément le
cas dans d'autres dans dans dans dans
des communes plus petitte plus rural
plus éloigné de de de d'apport euh
d'apport euh de de T de tous ordres hein
bien sûr donc euh effectivement moi je
parle au nom de la ville d'aras et je
pense qu'on est bien on est bien parti
pour dans quelques années pouvoir
mesurer cette le bien fondé de cette
réforme et encore une fois c'est bien
sûr l'intérêt de l'enfant que nous nous
nous avons euh nous avons
priorisé merci beaucoup madame beaumon
si j'ai bien compris c'est Monsieur
Bayel qui va prendre la suite pour
compléter alors oui je vais simplement
compléter quelques aspects par rapport à
la mise en place de la réforme et un
premier bilan des 5 premiers mois si
vous me permettez
effectivement nos collègues de ne
complèteront également et confirmeront
ce que ce que N ce que nous allons dire
entre le moment où nous avons abordé la
phase de concertation le bâti le projet
avec les parents et l'équipe enseignante
la phase opérationnelle est beaucoup
plus délicate et je peux vous dire que
on a vraiment mesurer la complexité de
cette réforme lorsque nous avons le 3
septembre démarré opérationnellement les
choses et je peux vous dire que ce qu'on
a repéré je pense qu'à ne c'est
peut-être un peu différent mais que les
parents se sont quand même impliqués
tardivement dans la réforme je veux dire
moi j'ai certains parents le jour de la
rentrée scolaire découvraent la réforme
des rythmes scolairire malgré malgré
tout le travail de communication tous
les support de communication que nous
avons pu mettre en place et c'est par
exemple 1300 familles sur les 2 500
familles qui ont des enfants scolarisés
à race qui n'avaient pas fait la
démarche vers l'espace famille he
puceque nous avons un espace numérique
qui permet aux familles sur le
territoire de pouvoir réserver la
restauration la la garderie et
maintenant les tap donc ça a été pour
nous dans l'opérationnalité quelque
chose de très difficile à gérer les
premiers jours et comme le disait madame
baumon surtout pour des questions de
responsabilité ou de transfert de
responsabilité entre le temps scolaire
et le temps périscolaire qui était bien
sûr nouveau le 3 septembre
ensuite vous dire également que la
gestion de des locaux a été pour nous un
un problème important on a quand je dis
un problème on les on on a réussi à les
résoudre mais on a senti quand même le
corps enseignant très réfractaire à
libéré leurs classes et malheureusement
nous à race nous n'avions pas à
proximité des des écoles des salles nous
permettant de délocaliser les tap et
puis parce que comme nous avions fait le
choix de 45 minutes nous souhaitions
préserver et limiter les temps de
déplacement des des enfants dans le
cadre des activités périscolaires donc
ça a été pour nous un travail de
persuasion près du corps enseignant pour
qu'ils nous laissent leur salle de
classe jusqu'à entendre parfois qu'on
désacralisit l'école voilà et que on
leur a dit que cétait quand même la
maison de la République l'école et qu'il
fallait la partager et puis si vous
voulez on peut dire que là où on a une
équipe enseignante dans beaucoup
d'écoles à aras coopératif qui ont
compris le sens de la réforme qui ont
très vite réajusté leur euh emploi du
temps quotidien parce que un enseignant
organise sa journée de classe on on a
très vite perçu que dans ces écoles-là
nous allions rentrer très vite dans des
ajustements chirurgicaux voilà c'était
des petits détails qui qui nous fallait
rég régler surtout après les vacances de
la toussa
euh on est parti pour je dirais aussi
apaiser ces tensions sur la gestion des
locaux sur un consensus avec l'Éducation
nationale pour l'élaboration au travers
de l'élaboration d'une charte
d'utilisation des locaux une charte de
bonne conduite et également sur les
questions de transfert de responsabilité
il nous fallait aussi euh bien bien
évidemment clarifier ces points-là euh
donc madame beaumon vous disait
effectivement que la situation est
plutôt maîtrisée aujourd'hui hein sur le
territoire les tensions sont apaisées on
est dans une démarche aujourd'hui de
consolidation et d'innovation sur les
les temps périscolaires et vous dire
également que notre inquiétude malgré
tout porte sur la fiabilité et surtout
la consolidation des équipes qui
interviennent sur les temps
périscolaires parce qu'on a peu de
turnover aujourd'hui mais on se dit
quand même qu'après chaque année
scolaire il va falloir
àassablement euh recommencer le travail
pour reconstituer les équipes équipes
que nous formons au fil de l'eau hein
bien évidemment sur sur des des temps de
formation et des temps de qualification
et puis comme le disait fort justement
madame Baumont nous avons eu une telle
exigence des parents au moment de la
concertation sur la qualification et la
qualité des intervenants et sur le
contenu des ateliers pédagogiques on
s'est laissé peut-être trop entraîner
sur un une un niveau de qualité qui a
fait qu'on s'est nous-même peut-être
pénaliser au démarrage parce que en
maternelle par exemple on s'est vite
aperçu jusqu'aux vacances de la toussin
que finalement nos nos modules étaient
peut-être trop élevés par rapport
peut-être moins ludique pas ludique et
donc tout le travail a été effectivement
de réajuster très vite sur ces ces
questionsl puis il y a eu effectivement
la recommandation du ministère de
l'intérie de de l'éducation qui nous ont
quand même nous a donné un peu quelques
pistes de réflexion pour ajuster nos nos
Thap effectivement ça pour nous en terme
de gestion des services cette réforme a
été comme le disait madame Beaumont une
révolution en terme de mode nous avons
fonctionné en mode projet au travers
d'un comité stratégique qui était
copiloté par l'Éducation nationale et le
maire d'aras avec en appui Madame
beaumon nous avons également impliqué
près d'une dizaines de directions qui
ont fait que ce projet là a été
largement partagé en transversalité et
qui a finalement nous a favorisé sa mise
en
application nous avons surtout Axès
également l'une des clés de la réussite
c'est qu'il fallait ne pas trop
perturber le quotidien des parents et
pour se faire nous avons donc dû
réajuster ou mettre en place des
dispositifs d'accompagnement des
familles sur deux niveaux d'abord une
demi-heure gratuite pour permettre aux
parents de de dans la nouvelle
organisation horaire de la journée de
s'y retrouver de ne pas être sous
pression par rapport notamment au
parents qui qui ont des activités
professionnelles donc ça ça a été une
mesure importante et apprécier des
parents et le deuxième point important
c'était la gestion du mercredi puisque
nous avons effectivement je dirais
favoriser le confort des parents en
maintenant une restauration le mercredi
et en privilégiant les transports des
écoles le mercredi midi vers les centres
de loisirs de la commune et donc
finalement ces mesures ont permis
d'apaiser également je dirais
d'éventuelles réaction des parents qui
auraient pu qui auraient pu finalement
entraîner une vague de de protestation
de contestation et de remettre et de
nous rendre plus compliqué encore la
mise en application de la réforme voilà
ce que je pouvais vous dire en
complément et je laisse bien
volontiers la parole à mes collègues de
ne qui viendront également enrichir nos
nos propos merci Monsieur Bayel en effet
nous sommes intéressés par l'exemple
de bonjour
euh écoutez c'est c'est étonnant parce
que j'ai l'impression d'être un peu dans
ma ville quand j'entends ce qui vient de
se
dire nous avons eu le temps d'échanger
tout à l'heure ensemble et effectivement
deux villes différentes mais des
parcours quand même semblables voilà
alors la ville de neverre j'ai envie de
dire donc moi je suis donc adjointe à
l'action éducative depuis
2011 suite à alors même chose Didier
boulot sénateur hein donc a laissé la
place à Florent saintfgardneau donc et
dans le cadre de
ce changement de d'équipe je suis donc
devenue adjointe à l'action éducative et
la jeunesse en remplaçant Martine
carillon couvreur qui est notre député
voilà que j'ai accompagné depuis 2001 en
charge donc de l'éducation en tant que
conseillère délégué donc moi j'arrive
avec le la réforme des rythme scolaire
et je dois dire que j'ai pris énormément
de plaisir à travailler euh pour mettre
en place cette réforme à neverre alors
neverre est une ville qui est ville amie
des enfants qui fait partie du réseau
français des villes éducatrices
euh nous avons toujours eu j'allais dire
une politique éducative très forte
d'ailleurs la la mise en place de la
réforme des rythmes scolaires a nous
nous a même permis c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure avec mes collègues
nous a permis de réaffirmer et de de
oui c'est ça de réaffirmer à la
population ce que la ville de Never
faisait en matière d'éducation et de
faire la différence entre ce qui est euh
les obligations les compétences
obligatoires et ce qu'une ville peut
faire en matière d'éducation et je
dirais même de co-éducation puisque nous
nous inscrivons complètement dans cette
démarche donc à ne depuis un certain
temps donc donc voilà donc passage en
2008 pour à la semaine de 4 jours donc
je suis pas adjointe à l'époque mais
l'équipe municipale déjà menée par
Didier boulot s'interroge sur cette
réforme sur le bienfait effectivement de
ces 4 jours et nous
proposons en en collaboration en échange
avec l'Éducation nationale
d'expérimenter sur deux écoles à never
donc à partir de 2010 nous nous
expérimentons sur une école qui éant
alors maintenant comment on dit on dit
plus RRS plus Z on dit comment REP voilà
pour être au goût du jour et une école
plus donc centrre-ville donc un travail
échange très fort avec l'Éducation
nationale avec les i avec les équipes
éducatives et une des premières
rencontres déjà avec les parents par
rapport donc à cette expérimentation
donc pour l'instant on parle absolument
pas de refondation de l'école mais on
est dans une démarche j'allais dire
d'une ville qui s'intéresse à
l'éducation
euh alors le sur le secteur l'école qui
fonctionne donc en r Oui une question
fondamentale vous avez décidé
d'expérimenter dans deux écoles les 4
jours et demi oui pardon excusez-moi
bien sûr excusez-moi les 4 jours et demi
suite effectivement à la loi de 2008
voilà donc on expériment et on on on on
part sur la semaine de 4 jour et demi
avec le mercredi matin et donc rencontre
avec les parents on met en place une
semaine où en fin de compte les le
l'école termine à 15h30 et de 15h30 à
16h30 des activités sont donc proposées
dans les écoles on se nous sommes
confrontés donc au aux parents sur la
zone RRS tout se passe très bien les
parents sont ravis les enfants sont
ravis d'avoir accès à des activités
auxquelles ils n'avaient pas accès
jusqu'à présent donc c'est déjà ce qui
nous a aussi interpellé sur l'autre
école qui est une école plus de
centrre-eville les enfants ont accès
déjà à toutes ces activités donc du coup
le mercredi matin il se trouent privé de
ces activités puisqu'ils ont école donc
on au bout d'un an l'école du
centre-ville donc arrête
l'expérimentation par contre nous la
poursuivons sur l'école en RRS donc
cette expérimentation nous a permis
naturellement de de mesurer justement
tout ça et de comprendre
qu'effectivement il faudra pour que ça
marche que tout le monde travaille
ensemble et grâce à grâce à cette
expérimentation sur cette
école le choix a été
effectivement évident nous a semblé
évident donc de mettre en place la
réforme des rythmes scolaires dès la
rentrée 2013 mais j'ai envie de dire que
cette expérimentation nous a
vraiment était nécessaire était
bénéfique pour pouvoir donc mettre en
place cette cette réforme euh ce que
j'aurais envie de dire aussi c'est que
l'équipe municipale euh auprès de notre
nouveau maire donc Florent
saintfergarneau c'est vraiment engagé et
ce qui a été très intéressant je trouve
dans dans dans cette réforme c'est que
les politiques publiques se sont
croisées à nouveau et l'adjoint à la
culture l'adjoint au sport l'adjoint aux
associations l'adjoint à l'éducation ont
vraiment eu une réflexion commune ça
existe mais là je veux dire on est sur
le terrain et on est obligé de le faire
donc à partir de de de 2000 je reprends
un peu conu note parce que là je suis
partie sur effectivement déjà une une
longue histoire
euh donc oui voilà donc c'était le
décalage des activités qui a posé
problème donc par rapport à cette autre
école donc cette expérimentation donc
effectivement nous a permis de repérer
les difficultés hein euh le temps de
midi les maternels alors on av'avait pas
eu on n pas eu encore avec cette école
on n'avait pas été confronté au problème
descisses et euh c'est vrai que nous
l'avons pas évoqué je pense que vous en
avez aussi sur votre territoire
mais j'aurais envie de dire que la
difficulté qu'on peut rencontrer en ce
moment c'est avec les publics fragiles
c'està-dire les maternels les enfants de
cliss où
effectivement je pense que ces enfants
ont besoin aussi de personnes formé et
par exemple on naccompagne pas un groupe
de Cliss de de 15h30 à
16h30 sans éducateur avec nous sans
enseignants avec nous bon là
effectivement je pense que euh on peut
avoir des réserves peut-être ou en tous
les cas euh une véritable réflexion à
voir pour améliorer ce temps-là alors
j'ai envie de dire aussi que euh je vous
cacherai pas que que que cette réforme
nous demande quand même une grande
ressource humaine hein de d'avoir quand
même
euh euh comment dire oui voilà de de
pouvoir euh euh faire appel aussi à des
gens qui sont qualifié des gens qui ont
envie aussi de le faire et euh et c'est
vrai qu'à ne donc on a proposé une
organisation un peu différente qui n'est
pas tous les jours parce qu'on a voulu
privilégier on navait pas les moyens de
mettre tous les jours 1 heure de de Tap
pour toutes les écoles nous avons 29
écoles à neverre 14 maternelles et donc
15 élémentairire et donc si on avait
voulu offrir à chaque école enfin à
chaque classe les moyens il nous fallait
180 intervenants hein donc nous chez
nous c'était pas possible voilà on
navait pas les moyens d'avoir tous ces
gens-là donc du coup on a fait une
proposition qui était de euh on a
redivisé notre ville en quatre nos
quatre cantons et en fin de compte nos
quatre secteurs et en fin de compte on
tourne mais peut-être que je laisserai
elodi veriser qui est directrice du
service donc enfance éducation et
jeunesse vous présenteer peut-être d'une
manière plus précise le l'organisation
que nous avons eu alors ce que j'ai
envie de dire c'est
que notre implication aussi dans le
réseau français des villes éducatrices
nous a beaucoup aidé c'est-à-dire que
moi je suis rentrée dans le bureau du du
réseau français des éducatrice il y a 2
ans effectivement on a vraiment
travaillé en lien d'ailleurs j'invite na
ville Darras à nous rejoindre parce que
je trouve que ce ce cette cette
association est est forte et nous a
permis effectivement vra vraiment de de
de partager nos expériences chaque ville
a une histoire différente et en même
temps ça nous a permis de d'échanger
d'avancer ensemble de comparer euh donc
voilà ça j'ai trouvé que c'était aussi
très intéressant
euh ce que j'ai envie de dire aussi donc
c'est que donc nous avons un mode de
fonctionnement euh issu donc de notre
expérimentation donc qui a duré donc 3
ans
et ce qui pu ce que j'ai aimé aussi dans
la mise en place de cette réforme c'est
cette rencontre qu'on a eu aussi avec la
population tout ça au service des
enfants et ça a même permis je dirais à
des
parents de de se dire mais en fin de
compte les préoccupations qu'on a c'est
les nôtres et c'est pas celle de nos
enfants et du coup ça replace l'enfant
au centre du du débat et cette réforme
moi je la trouve très riche pour ça et
c'est effectivement à nous de pouvoir
l'accompagner le mieux possible ble
euh j'aurais envie de dire quand même
que la Nièvre je vais parler je parle de
neevre mais la Nièvre quand même c'est
un département très rural et je sens
quand même des différenciations entre
les communes mon never on est une ville
on est la le chef lieu du département et
donc effectivement on a un tissu
associatif on a toute une vie culturelle
et sportif qui nous permet effectivement
de de nous appuyer sur ces réseauxl pour
pouvoir mettre la réforme le mieux
possible
euh ce que j'ai trouvé aussi intéressant
c'est vraiment le travail avec
l'Éducation nationale je pense que avant
quand on se rencontrait on parlait de
carte scolaire on parlait de suppression
de classe surtout chez nous et là on
parle de construction de coéducation et
tout ça au service de l'enfant et ça je
trouve que c'est vraiment un point très
fort dans cette
réforme ça nous empêche pas de parler de
car de cartes scolair mais du coup je
trouve qu'on on avance on avance
ensemble
et on avance vraiment au profit donc de
de de du bien-être de l'enfant
et ce qui a été aussi intéressant c'est
le lien avec les enseignants c'estàd
qu'on a demander aussi aux enseignants
de réfléchir à ce qui pouvait être
complémentaire
justement à leur à leur projet
pédagogique pour que justement les
enfants soient en capacité de pouvoir
euh découvrir
expérimenter des choses qu'on n pas
forcément le temps de faire en classe
parce que il ne reste quand même que 24h
d'école voilà euh moi j'aurais presque
souhaité qu'on revienne à 27h et qu'on
continue la mise en place effectivement
de ce temps-là mais c'est vrai il y a
que 24 heures d'école donc je pense que
cette cette proposition peut nous
permettre d'être sur un volet de
découverte et d'épanouissement de
l'enfant
voilà merci infiniment de ce tour
d'horizon madame verisser je vais encore
donner la parole ensuite à Madame
Marignan simplement sachez que le temps
tourne nous avons beaucoup de questions
et nous attendons beaucoup de réponses
de votre part aussi merci d'être précis
comme vous l'avez fait jusqu'à présent
merci bonjour à tous donc je suis
lodivier RER la directrice d'éducation à
la mairie de ne donc je va juste
compléter rapidement ce qu'a pu dire
Pascal Massico qui élu euh donc à nous
avons mis en place la réforme en
septembre 2013 euh grâce à une
mobilisation politique important
importante et un investissement
important du maire et de son adjoint à
travers une organisation très
participative enessayant d'associer au
maximum les partenaire éducatif de la
collectivité euh Neev a su être
trésactif par rapport au regard d'un
calendrier ministériel serré et
euh le cadre le cadre le cadre du décret
était peu interprétatif mais ça nous a
permis aussi d'imaginer un
fonctionnement qui collé à notre à notre
réalité à savoir que on a expérimenté
comme l'a dit Pascal Massico pendant 3
ans un fonctionnement sur deux écoles de
neure euh on a libéré les enfants donc
on a mis en place la semaine de 4 jours
et demi en libérant les enfants à 15h30
et on a proposé aux enfants des
activités périscolaires euh à partir de
15h30 4 jours par semaine quand on a
voulu mettre en place le décret la
réforme des septembrees 2013 mettre en
euh mettre en place un tel projet à
l'échelle de la ville nécessité comme
l'a dit Pascal Massico de mobiliser 180
intervenants tous les soirs on n pas les
moyens techniques à N ver qui est une
commune rurale et qui n'est pas une
commune enfin une ville universitaire de
mobiliser ses ressources humaines donc
avait un aspect financier qui nous
permettit pas de le faire mais également
on nait pas les moyens humains à
mobiliser donc on a essayé de trouver
une un fonctionnement qui est le suivant
donc on a 4 jours de de fonctionnement
on a quatre cantons à ne et donc une
fois par semaine les enfants terminent
la classe à 14h45 et on propose des
activités péréscolaires de 14h45 à 16h
et les trois autres jours de la semaine
les enfants ont classe jusqu'à 16h donc
pour la ville ça a nécessé de mettre en
place de nouveaux services donc ce qu'on
appelle les temps d'activités
périscolaires les tapes ce qu'on appelle
maintenant les nappes les nouveaux
nouvelles activités périscolaires une
fois par semaine selon les écoles donc
selon où se trouve l'école dans le dans
le ver le lundi sur un quartier le mardi
ailleurs euh donc on a mis en place des
tapes on a mis en place d'autres
services comme à Haras des garderies
gratuites de 16h à 16h30 également des
des services nouveaux les mercredis une
garderie gratuite mais également une
restauration pour tous les enfants les
mercredis pour les parents qui le
souhaitent euh pour mettre en place ce
projet on s'est appuyé sur
l'expérimentation qu'on a mené pendant 3
ans qui nous a permis
euh d'acquérir une expérience notamment
sur un aspect opérationnel et d'être
tout de suite vigilant sur certains
aspects dès septembre euh on a mené
cette expérimentation comme l'a dit
Pascal Massico en réseau avec d'autres
villes et on a notamment mis en place
des des évaluations de nos
expérimentations qui montrent qu'on a
des points communs entre les différentes
villes et on a des points de vigilance
commun pour mettre en place le projet on
a travaillé de manière partenariale de
manière importante Pascal Masco l'a dit
avec l'inspection avec l'ensemble des
partenaires éducatifs on a travaillé
avec des enseignants qui étaient inquiet
qu'on peut qualifier un petit peu
d'attentiste mais qui sont quand même
facilitants ils nous ont pas mis de
bâton dans les roues pour mettre en
place le projet sur nere et au contraire
ils ont plutôt été vigilants avec nous
on a dû mettre en place un
accompagnement spécifique pour les
familles qui étai particulièrement
inquiète et ça ça nous a ça a nécessité
qu'on mettre en place des outils de
communication spécifiques de revoir nos
outils de
communication ce projet nous a permis
enfin plus généralement la refondation
de l'école est le point de départ pour
nous de une véritable structuration de
de coéducation au sein de la au sein de
du territoire et notamment ça nous a
permis de repositionner le rôle pivot de
la de la commune enfin de la
collectivité dans ce fonctionnement de
de
coéducation puisque ça nous a c'est nous
qui avons joué le rôle de relais entre
les différents partenaires pour qu'ils
se connaissent et se
reconnaissent on a replacé l'enfant en
cur des réflexions on a jamais autant
parlé d'éducation que de depuis qu'on
parle de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires par contre on a en matière de
coéducation un point de vigilance à
souligner concernant le mil000feuille
qu'on a pu créer à travers les outils on
nous ne était déjà doté d'un projet
éducatif local on a dû se doter d'un
projet éducatif de territoire on avait
aussi un contrat enfantjeunesse enfin
voilà on se retrouve avec une multitude
d'outils qui demande et c'est ce qu'on
va faire dans la deuxième enfin dans la
phase qu'on a qu' entamé une voilà une
remise à plein un peu de tous ces outils
pour permettre une une véritable
cohérence entre l'ensemble de concernant
tous ces outils concernant les publics
euh un petit peu contrairement à ras le
l'expérimentation qu'on a mené nous
montrait qu'on risquait d'avoir une
fréquentation importante de ces
nouvelles activités on était parti sur
on avait envisagé 80 % de fréquentation
dès octobre on avait 90 % de
fréquentation on monte jusqu'à 98 % pour
certaines pour certaines écoles sachant
que pour les traditionnellement pour les
autres activités péréscolaires je pense
les garderies après 16h30 on a 10 %
d'enfants fréquentant ces garderies donc
voilà ça vous permet d'avoir un une
réflexion une un objet de comparaison
euh euh donc Pascal je reviens Pascal
mass a parlé de de l'intérêt pour les
enfants d'avoir une activité
périscolaire supplémentaire je
reviendrai pas dessus par contre on les
enseignants nous font part dès à présent
déjà de la plusvalue d'avoir une
demi-journée d'apprentissage
supplémentaire qui est celle du mercredi
matin Pascal Massico vous a parlé de la
vigilance qu'on avait sur les
maternelles puisque voilà on avait aussi
des ambitions éducatives importantes
concernant les maternelles on les
maintient mais il nous faut être
vigilant notamment pour les repérages
spatiau-temporels pour ces ces enfantsl
concernant un autre point de vigilance
concerne les enfants en situation de
handicap Pascal mico vous parlez de la
difficulté qu'on avait anticipé en
mettant en place déjà un groupe de
travail spécifique pour ce ces enfantsl
là où on se pose la là où là où on
constate un manque de visibilité c'est
sur les interventions notamment des AVS
sur les temps périscolaires et un manque
de lisibilité sur la participation
financière enfin sur le financement de
ces interventions là donc la
participation des AVS sur les temps
d'activité périscolaire et sur la
formation des intervenants qui
interviennent sur ce public là
concernant le les emplois générés par ce
ce ce temps d'activité périscolaire ils
sont réels juste pour la collectivité la
collectivité de never a créer c c emplo
CIN équivalents temps plein net ça a
également créé des emplois sur les
associations j'ai pas de chiffre à vous
donner par contre ça peut ça a généré
des emplois plutôt précaires au niveau
des
associations concernant les emplois et
les intervenants ça nécessite qu'on soit
vigilant sur les la formation de ces
intervenants et ne on se pose déjà la
question sur un un plan de formation
plutôt global et pour permettre de
croiser l'ensemble des des compétences
des uns et des autres un exemple nos
adsem ont participeré à une formation
proposée aux enseignants en début
d'année donc voilà c'est on va on va
vraiment plus loin en matière de
coéducation enfin concernant les aspects
financiers Neev à
mobiliser enfin à mobiliser des moyens
comme l'a dit Pascal Massico de manière
importante les moyens qui ont été
mobilisés représentent une augmentation
du budget de l'éducation consacré à
l'éducation de 5 %
euh ce qui est pas négligeable quand on
a mis en
place la réforme donc en mai juin quand
on s'interroger on peut souligner que on
avait quand même une absence
d'information de la part des partenaires
institutionnels notamment au niveau de
la CAF sur le soutien qu'on pouvait
avoir on commence à avoir des réponses
là depuis septembre mais quand on a mis
en place on avait quand même une
incertitude voilà donc conclusion c'est
une réforme qui est vraiment importante
et qui nécessite d'être d'être
accompagné d'être amélioré mais ça
nécessite de de garder le
cap merci beaucoup pour cet exemple très
très intéressant également madame de
Marignon est-ce que vous souhaitz donner
un positionnement par rapport à la
Fédération des villes moyennes nous dire
aussi peut-être combien de villes se
sont lancées dans cette dans
l'organisation des des rythmes scolaires
et si toutes les expérimentations enfin
en oui les expériences que vous avez
jusqu'à présent les remontées sont
toutes aussi positives que celles que
nous avons entendu ce jour oui donc 41
villes moyennes se sont lancé dans l'
l'expérimentation donc 26 %
et d'après les enquêtes qu'on a mené les
les expériences de la ville de d'aras et
ne ver sont sont très représentatives
donc je vais peut-être simplement vous
vous laissz leur poser vos vos
questions merci beaucoup la parole est à
madame le rapporteur alors moi j'ai
quelques merci d'abord pour un voté
témoignage votre enthousiasme apporter
cette belle réforme et félicitations
pouvoir ténacité euh donc alors des
questions très même très très concrètes
don une
première c'est vous madame de la ville
d'aras qui avait dit que il y avait eu
des problèmes les enseignants ça avait
été un peu compliqué euh par rapport en
particulier à la plage méridienne
comment vous avez levé les rétisence et
est-ce que est-ce que vous êtes passé
j'ai pas bien suivi de rétissence à
adhésion ou vous êtes passé simplement à
neutralité bon ça ça sera une première
question je continue est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire le coûte des rythmes
pour la ville
de alors en particulier est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire le pourcentage par
rapport à vos dépenses de fonctionnement
voilà qu'on est qu'on est qu'on est un
niveau le coûte vous nous direz si c'est
le coûte subvention déduite ou le coûte
avant subvent tion donc même question
parce que pour la ville de neverre Le
coûte en pourcentage et dépenses de
fonctionnement et est-ce que c'est avant
subvention ou après subvention et après
j'ai dû être inattentive c'est sur
l'organisation de votre semaine vous
avez donc dit euh vous libérez une
après-midi ou 2 après-midi à
1h15 vous j'ai entendu euh une fois par
semaine ça s'arrêterait à 14h45 euh les
autres jours donc cela va jusqu'à 16h et
comment on retrouve alors le le le le
temps nécessaire libérer l'allègement le
mercredi matin c'est combien d'heures
mais là c'est parce que j'ai pas été
assez attentive donc
voilà je vous donne la
parole je vais répondre la première donc
à votre première question je crois qu'on
va faire un exercice à deux voix avec
Monsieur Bayol donc concernant les
enseignants qui étaient plutôt réticents
et comme je vous l'ai dit qui concernent
plutôt les écoles maternelles puisque
cette ce ce temps de ce temps
périscolaire est est placé à 13h15 euh
effectivement la rétiscence venait de
d'un certain nombre de de de directeurs
d'école directrices qui ou enfin et
leurs enseignants euh mais je crois que
on a vraiment eu le je dirais la l'appui
très fort et très euh très pertinent et
très pédagogique de la l'inspectrice de
circonscription hein nous avons vraiment
travaillé euh ensemble euh et je pense
qu'elle a elle a convaincu ces ces ces
équipes que c'était une un bon sens
qu'il fallait avoir parce que sinon les
petits euh dans la mesure où ont plçait
les les les les fameux tap en fin de
journée bah les petits n'avaient plus de
n'avaient plus de de temps de temps de
d'école de temps de de scolarité
obligatoire donc je vous dis ça a été un
moment de de discussion mais fortement
appuyé par
l'inspectrice qui pour le coup a été
tout à fait convaincante et qui les a
convaincu et franchement allez il y a
peut-être dans dans dans dans dans le
groupe de de ces de ces équipes de ces
14 écoles maternel il y a peut-être une
école où c'est un petit peu plus
difficile bon mais ça ça reste ça reste
exceptionnel on se rend compte les
parents bon se rendre compte que bien
sûr les tout petits Siest siestent
indispensable et ça c'est quelque chose
d'incontournable les tap les feront plus
tard quand ils seront plus grands hein
c'est ce qu'on dit parce que ça aussi on
l'entendait quelquefis vous savez d'une
manière un peu spontanée ah bah ils vont
pas faire de ils n'auront pas de Tap
mais bon voilà c'est vraiment une
question madame bon pardonnez-moi le le
temps pour très très vite je vous
demanderai à chacune et à chacun d'être
très très bref et vraiment donner une
réponse au questionnement de Mad réponse
je pense que vous l'avez merci beaucoup
je vais vous répondre mais ce qui a été
aussi déterminant simplement pour
compléter ce que disait madame baaumon
ça a été aussi l'implication du daen
lorsqu'on a lorsque l'inspectrice a
transféré nos C les C protocoles qui ont
été élaboré suite aux réunions de
concertation et dans les conseils
d'école le daen a réuni les où ça cause
des problèmes avec l'équipe éducative
les parents d'élèves représentant
l'ensemble des parents des écoles et la
collectivité et ça a été cette réunion
qui a permis finalement de d'apaiser et
de faciliter la la décision du daen
lorsqu'il a dû choisir le protocole qui
a été celui proposé par la ville d'aras
bon mais voilà cé c'est comme ça sur le
coup pour la ville d'Arras c'est 12 % du
budget aujourd'hui en plus l'impact de
la réforme des rythmes scolaires alors
en euros nous avons 956000 € de dépenses
complémentaires qui se décompose comme
suit hein pour vous donner vraiment une
idée 72000 € Le coût supplémentaire de
la gestion du mercredi et 894000 € pour
la gestion des temps périscolaires nous
avons recruté 178 intervenants voilà et
le budget de fonctionnement total c'est
combien de de de de de la ville ou du de
la ville c'est 70 millions d'eurosou
donc c'est 956000 non c'est pas 12 % le
coût de la politique éducation est de 7
millions d'euros oui voilà non c'est 12
% de la politique éducation en plus mais
70 millions d'euros c'est 956000 sur 70
millions c'est le budget total de
fonctionnement je recommence le budget
de la ville d'aras c'est 70 million
d'euros oui le coût de la politique
éducation pour la ville d'Arras avant la
réforme c'était 6200000 €. après la
réforme c'est 7 millions ça veut dire
900 l'impact de la réforme pour le
budget c'est 966000 €
et effectivement le coût net après les
subventions et dotations d'État il est
de 700000 € voilà et pardon budget total
donc moi je voudrais budget de
fonctionnement de la vie de la race 70
milli c'est fonctionnement
fonctionnement oui oui je dis oui oui
fonctionnement alors sur le coût et sur
les sur les subventions effectivement je
pense que mes collègues de ne
l'évoqueront également c'est on a un
problème final
sur les financements que qu'on nous
incite d'aller chercher à la CAF dans le
cadre et
effectivement la CAF conditionne l'aide
le versement de l'aide complémentaire à
la déclaration préalable des temp
périscola en accueil de mineurs
conformément aux dispositions du code de
l'actionent sociale et des familles et
je peux vous dire que les contraintes
inhérante à ces déclarations sont à la
fois lourdes et coûteuses et et nous
incite finalement
quasiment ne pas aller chercher ses
financements alors on se disait alors on
est en négociation avec notre Direction
Départementale de la Cohésion Sociale en
leur demandant de faire un peu un peu
plus preuve de souplesse parce que à un
moment donné faire une déclaration comme
chez nous si centres de d'accueil
collectif de mineur je peux vous dire
avec les contraintes administratives que
ça impose en terme de norm et cetera
qu'on nous réclame je peux vous dire que
c'est 3 mois de travail à temps plein
pour préparer les dossiers donc à ce
jour dans les out que vous nous donnez
vous n'intégrez pas les 54 € possibles
de la CAF c'est hor financement CAF donc
s'il y avait les financements CAF on
rediminue encore le C moitié ou oui
d'accord mais c'est vraiment un parcours
du combattant pour aller chercher ses
financement et ça si vous pouvez faire
quelque chose ça serait très
bien j'ai bien compris pour la ville de
neverre alors moi je vais vous parler
des horaires donc ne donc on nous nous
sommes nous avons dit diviser la ville
en 4 donc par exemple le lundi nous
fonctionnons nous av nous faisons 8h30
11h45 13h45
14h45 et à partir de 14h45 il y a le
temps euh le T qui se met en place et le
mardi alors sinon les horaires c'est
8h30
11h45 13h45 16h les autres jours c'est
ça donc après le mardi c'est un autre
secteur le jeudi c'est un autre secteur
le vendredi c'est un are secteur et
après on tournera sidalement il y a un
secteur qui finit le vendredi à 13h à
14h45 donc il faudra partager voilà euh
sinon je tenais que aussi à préciser
qu'on a on a une véritable volonté aussi
de laisser les 2h sur la pause
méridienne hein euh dans la réforme on
nous demandait de respecter 1h30 nous on
a des secteurs où enfin des des écoles
on a deux services on a vraiment tenu à
garder la qualité de ce temps et donc on
na pas cédé sur le raccourcissement de
donc de la pause méridienne voilà je
laisser la parole à Madame veriser pour
parler des
finances donc concernant les finances le
budget de la ville de ne c'est dans
fonctionnement est de 50 millions le
budget consacré le budget de
fonctionnement consacré à l'éducation
est 7 milons 7 et le budget dans ces 7
millions dans c'est 7li7 le budget
consacré non c'est pas dans 50 millions
la ville 77 le budget consacré au rythme
470000 € dans ces 470000 € on compte les
temps d'activités périscola mais
également tous les impacts périphériques
à savoir le chauffage des écoles le
mercredi matin le remplacement des adsem
voà sur d'autres temps et cetera c'est
tout compris les les impacts
supplémentaires et ça représente donc
les 462000 ça représente 5 % du budget
éducation et en recette pour l'instant
on a 150000 € de l'État et on est dans
la même démarche carass essayer de de de
de passer nos temps d'activité péréscola
en accueil de loisirs pour nous
permettre d'avoir des recettes de la CAF
mais effectivement ce que je vous dis
tout à l'heure ça nécessite des un un
travail important avec la CAF et avec la
DD CSPP
voilà merci beaucoup monsieur
Carl merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais d'abord remercier mesdames et
monsieurs de la présentation de leur
projet les les félicité d'avoir réussi à
le mettre en place qui est pas le cas
malheureusement de toutes les villes
qu'elles soient petite grande ou moyenne
puisqu'il y en a moins de 4000 sur 20
plus de 20000 communes qui ont euh une
école et justement pour essayer de faire
avancer les choses si vous deviez donner
des conseils à vos collègues quels sont
j'allis dire les ou plutôt quels
seraient les freins à lever pour faire
avancer les choses et puis petite
question subsidiaire qu concernant les
coûts est-ce que vous pourriez nous
donner un chiffre apporté à
l'élève la réponse à madame monsieur bel
le coût par élève à race c'est 214
€. 214 € par élève vous avez fait le
calcul à NRE 180 € par an et par enfant
180 € par an et par enfant voilà réponse
à votre question merci beaucoup monsieur
Carl nous avons souhaité vous inviter
auj aujourd'hui pour une audition dans
le cadre de la mission commune
d'information que nous menons
tambourbattan depuis quelques mois déjà
pour tenter de dégager quelles sont les
problématiques les contraintes les
freins et y apporter le cas échéant les
solutions les plus adaptées pour une
mise en œuvre de cette réforme donc
notre temps étant très contraint je vous
donne immédiatement la parole pour une
présentation monsieur le Président suivi
des questions de madame le rapporteur et
enfin suivi des questions de nos nos
collègues ici présents auquel je vous
remercie par avance de bien vous Leir
apporter une réponse monsieur
desto c'est pas quilà hein c'est c'est
bon madame la Présidente merci de de
maccueillir ma madame la rapporteur
merci d'être également présent pour cet
échange qui me semble effectivement
extrêmement intéressant et je remerci le
le Sénat d'en faire un point important
de de sa réflexion et de son évaluation
les rythme scolairire vu par les grandes
villes et peut-être devrais-je commencer
par rappeler à ce qu l'association des
mers des grandes villes ce que signifie
grandes villes dans cette
acception ce sont les villes de plus de
100000 habitants villes et
agglomérations aujourd'hui qui vont se
structurer d'ailleurs de façon un petit
peu différente contte tenu de la loi
décentralisation du premier texte qui
est paru en décembre avec les
communautés d'agglomération les
communautés urbaines les métropoles de
droits commun et les trois grandes
métropoles comme vous savez Paris Lyon
et Marseille alors c'est un ensemble
important t que représentation de la
population en nombre de communes ramelé
aux 36000 communes française c'est
évidemment une toute petite poignée et
donc ça n'a pas vocation tout ce que je
vais vous dire à représenter l'ensemble
de l'échantillon français mais en terme
de population c'est évidemment un
ensemble qu'on a volu à peu près 60 % de
la population française même si il n'y a
que 48 villes de plus de 100000
habitants et donc autant puisqu'elles
sont toutes encommunalités et avec les
intercommunalités on double G DIRIS le
nombre de de
structures pratiquement toutes les
villesagglomération
était favorable à l'idée de mettre en
place un nouveau rythme scolaire il n'y
avait pas je dirais une opposition à
priori à la mesure qui était souhaitée
par par le le gouvernement certaines
même dans la nôtre la mienne la ville de
Grenoble avait déjà initié cette foisé
en début de mandat un débat avec la
population et notamment avec les parents
d'élèves et les différentes structures
scolaires l'idée qu'on puisse passer à 4
jours et
demi laamf comme vous le savez
l'association des MRES de France a fait
une enquête auprès des des communes qui
ont décidé d'adopter la réforme en
2013 qui révèle que
93 83 pardon pour des communes qui ont
répondu à
l'enquête considère qu'ils ont pu le
faire avec un certain taux de
satisfaction ceux qui ne veut pas dire
hein qu'il n'y a pas un certain nombre
de problèmes nous-même nous
avons commenter cette enquête et
regarder à l'intérieur de notre propre
association quels étaient les les points
les points forts les points de
satisfaction et au contraire les points
d'inquiétude et les points de critique
qui pouvaent y
avoir plus de trois communes sur 4 c'est
77 % exactement
rapportent avoir eu des difficultés pour
financer la réforme plus de 6/ 10 estime
dépensé entre 100 et 200 € par enfant et
par an alors la four peut sembler
importante mais il est évident que ça
dépend évidemment ce que chaque commune
met dans le périscolaire et quel est son
niveau de d'engagement nousmême
d'ailleurs association des m des grandes
villes dans les négociations discussions
que nous avions eu avec l'État avec le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et le
Premier ministre avion évoqué une
moyenne d'engagement de 150 € par enfant
et parents donc on était pas loin du
compte il y en a même qui vont plus loin
puisque moiême dans la propre commune je
dépasse les les 200 on doit arriver à
200 230 on a voulu peut-être être un pe
aé mais en tout cas on voit que ça n'est
pas ça n'est pas marginal donc on peut
avoir un taux de satisfaction globale
important et un taux
de je je
dirais d'interrogation hein sur je
dirais l'engagement financier et le et
le rapport si j'ose dire entre les
sources qui nous sont données par l'État
et les engagements de des communes qui
est pas forcément aussi satisfaisant en
tout cas pour les responsables que que
nous
sommes nous estimons
euh que pour mettre en œuvre cette
semaine de 4 jours et
demi plus de la moitié des communes ont
dû recruter du personnel et notamment
des animateurs une proportion qui
atteint les 2/ers dans les les communes
urbaines mais près de 40 % disent avoir
eu des difficultés à les recruter alors
c'est très variable hein selon les les
les villes je peux je pense qu'on ne
peut pas donner des des résultats qui ne
soient exactement les mêmes pour tous le
taux de fréquentation par les élèves est
aussi une grande inconnue de la phase de
préparation de la réforme qui a fait la
difficulté hein dans la mise en place de
de de de cette réforme et bien souvent
on a procédé par itération c'est-à-dire
une première évaluation au bout d'un
mois une seconde évaluation au bout de
de 2 mois ou d'un trimestre ce qui
explique d'ailleurs que les premières
indications n'étaient pas forcément très
très bonne car il y a eu une difficulté
d'accueil bien souvent rapporté par les
parents qui disaient que leurs enfants
étaient fatigués alors il y avait
évidemment toujours de choses parce que
les enfants sont toujours fatigués au MO
de septembre he c'estàdire que la
reprise de l'école est toujours et les
parents devraient le savoir mais chaque
année ils redisaient il redisent la même
chose et là il l'avait attribué
évidemment au rythme scolaire mais il y
avait aussi le fait hein que comme
l'organisation scolaire et périscolaire
était une nouveauté qu'elle n'était pas
rodée il était évident qu'ils avaient
l'impression qu'ils étaient dans le
scolaire hein plus longtemps d'où cette
impression évidemment de de fatigue
impression réalité hein qui était
rapporté y compris par des gens qui
étaient favorables à la mesure alors
deuxème grande grand point les les
mesures annoncées par le gouvernement
bon moi-même j'avais expliqué au Premier
ministre que fond
d'amorçage
était une bonne chose parce que démar il
y avait rien du tout mais comme dans une
entreprise fondage le terme était repris
vous savez hein au monde au monde de
l'entreprise les start-up ont droit des
fonds d'amorçage pu après quand on est
plus start-up il faut être accompagné
donc il y a d'autres mesures
d'accompagnement pour que une start-up
devienne une petite entreprise une
petite entreprise devienne une moyenne
entreprise une moyenne entreprise
devienne une entreprise de taille
intermédiaire une entreprise de taille
intermédiaire devient un grand groupe et
un grand groupe devient un grand groupe
international alors on cherche pas
forcément à faire des multinationales on
cherche à ce qu'il y ait un parcours de
développement et qui nécessite un
accompagnement pérenne et donc je
proposais qu' qu'on aille au-delà du
fond d'amorçage alors on est encore je
dirais j'ose pas parler d'ambiguité mais
enfin dans une formule
d'assouplissement aujourd'hui des
premiers engagements du du Premier
ministre puisque première année 2e année
ceux qui étaient d'accord ce qui est pas
d'accord tout le monde y a droit il
n'empêche qu'il faudra bien continuer en
tout cas de notre point de vue à
maintenir un rapport de force avec le
gouvernement et le ministre de
l'éducation nationale pour péréniser qu
à ce qu'il y ait des formules de
d'gressivité progressive hein pour ne
pas d'abord pénaliser les bons élèves
qui comme nous ont commencé dès la
première année ce serait quand même le
monde à l'envers deuxièmement hein
permettre à ce que cette mesure hein qui
est toujours un peu plus difficile au
démarrage et bien si on veut
véritablement qu'elle Ré 6 puisse être
accompagné sur une période suffisamment
longue pour prendre évidemment un essort
constant de ce point de vue-là il est
tout à fait évident que nous devons
regarder non seulement l'argent sonnant
et tribuchant mais aussi toutes les
autres mesures d'accompagnement parmi
celle-là c'est comme vous le savez
l'assouplissement des taux d'encadrement
du périscolaire qui était une demande
fortement faite par l'ensemble des
associations
euh d'élèves euh qui doit être de notre
point de vue élargi à l'ensemble des
heures du périscolaire et non pas
simplement aux 3 heures qui ont été
retenues et nous demandons qu'au terme
de l'année
2014-2015 une évaluation puisse être
faite afin de discuter des suites à
donner c'està c'est pas une réforme qui
est partie et qui est maintenant tout le
monde a on serait d'accord ou pas
d'accord mais on y reviendrait pas elle
ne peut se concevoir que s'il y a
effectivement évaluation alors nous
proposons un certain piste de
d'amélioration d'abord l'action de notre
association qui avait porté sur la
pérénisation des financements
l'harbonisation des taux d'encadrement
j'en ai parlé et le rendu des projets
éducatifs territoriaux hein nous la nous
nous disons elle semble avoir
partiellement porté c'estd tout tout ce
que je dis étai des têtes de chapitres
qui ont fait l'objet de négociations
avec l'État ou avec d'autres partenaires
toutefois des inconnus subsistent encore
notamment concernant les financements
des
CAF il ne suffit pas de négocier au plan
national entre un premier ministre et
puis un un président et un directeur
général caisse nationale d'allocation
familial pour que les choses soient
réglées certes des choses ont été
définies dans une convention d'objectif
et de gestion signée en juillet 2013
limitant de fait l'accès
euh à ses financements par les communes
mais il nous faut absolument instituer
une contractualisation
entre les communes elles-mêmes et les
CAF pour les prestations du
service les prestations de service
ordinaires et l'inscrire dans la
périnité c'estàd dans le long terme
dans la mesure où elle représente un
montant plus important que le fond
d'amorçage disons-le clairement et ne
sont pas remises en cause chaque année
par la loi de finances je dis d'autant
plus que une fois encore il faudrait pas
que ce soit les bons élèves qui soient
pénalisés comme vous le savez enfin je
évidemment je parle de ma commune que je
connais mieux que que que les autres
communes mais nous avons pas attendu la
réforme des rythmes scolaires pour
contractualiser avec les cas decation
criminal c'est ce que nous pouvions
faire dans dans dans dans ce domainelà
et il faudrait pas qu'on nous explique
que comme vous avez déjà beaucoup reçu
parce qu'on a aussi beaucoup donné
précédemment on est on est plus plus
droit à rien je sais pas si je me fais
bien comprendre hein de madame la
Présidente le rapporteur j'aimerais que
ce soit bien inscrit dans le
contte-rendu hein il n'est pas possible
hein que des bons élèv soi pénalisé dans
cette affaire et que nous ne pouvons pas
voir là comme ailleurs hein des règles
générales universelles parce qu'un
premier ministre discute avec un
directeur général ou un président au
niveau nationale c'est un peu comme la
loi de décentralisation hein on essaie
de faire rentrer dans une dans la même
chaussure des choses qui sont très
différentes il y a des régions et des
régions il y a départements des
départements il y a des grandes villes
des villes moyennes des petites villes
il onont faire une loi universelle voyez
la difficulté que ça peut représenter on
fait des métropoles bah oui mais il y a
la moitié des régions il y aura pas de
métropole donc forcément on peut pas
effectivement avoir des mêmes règles
pour tout le monde et bien je dis que si
on ne décline pas au niveau de chaque
caisse d'allocation familiale et bien on
va faire des blagues parce que on ne
peut pas avoir une loi universelle
d'application voilà ensuite conformément
à l'annonce du Premier ministre la knaf
a validé l'assouplissement des taux
d'encadrement au-delà des 3 heures
nouvellement à la charge des communes
cette décision est pour le moment
contonné la seule période courant du 1er
janvier au 5 juillet donc de de notre
année 2014 un conseil d'administration
de la knaf devait se réunir en mai pour
évaluer la pertinence de cet
assouplissement et réévaluer son coût il
est important que cette mesure soit
reconduite sur un temps plus
long à l'échelle des peu d'été c'estàd
sur 3 ans voilà ce que nous souhaitons
qui semble être de bon sens hein pour la
mise en place d'une mesure de de cette
nature alors au-delà des coûts
importants pour la
commune les échos des des grandes villes
qui sont passé au nouveau rythme
scolaire donc dès cette rentrée de
septembre
2013 pointe vers une mise en œuvre moins
compliquée qu'anticipée des ajustements
ont souvent été nécessaair pour
surmonter les difficultés initiales
l'intelligence locale tente à
s'organiser en fait bon on s c'est très
bien à partir du moment où il y a une
volonté on a voulu le faire bah on a
tout fait pour que ça marche le mieux
possible toutefois les solutions
adoptées en 2013 2014 sont souvent
éphémères et posent le problème de toute
la pérénisation des dispositifs au-delà
de tout ce que j'ai dit on retrouve
toujours le même thème hein comment au
fond ce qui est un amorçage doit être un
accompagnement c'est comme quand on crée
une entreprise il y a une start-up il y
a un patron il a sa secrétaire il
recrute son premier ingénieur son
premier technicien sa première
assistante de de communication et puis
après ben on en recrute d'autres et oui
c'est ça c'est comme ça et et qu'est-ce
qu'on fait après bah oui ben le fond
d'amorçage permet hein de franchir les
premiers mois d'aller faire les courses
d'aller au restaurant et puis après
quand il faut acheter des davantage de
locaux acheter des machines prendre un
billet d'avion pour aller à l'étranger
pour vendre toute sa camelotte il faut
un peu plus d'argent bah c'est la même
chose hein quand on monte une politique
de rythme scolaire il faut pouvoir
accompagner tout ça je
termine en parlant de l'enjeu de la
professionnalisation des acteurs du
périscolaire qui nous semble absolument
déterminant pour maintenir les
dispositifs identifiés dans le temps et
dans la qualité le métier d'animateur
s'en trouvera renforcé et gagnera en
reconnaissance et les inquiétudes
soulevées par l'assouplissement des taux
d'encadrement et la conduite des
activités périscolaires seront
apisé ation des emplois d'avenir adaptés
au nouveau rythme avec les ajustements
préconisés par les grandes villes et la
prise en charge d'une offre de formation
dédiée les BAFA par
exemple qui peuvent être pris en charge
notamment en terme de de qualification
de formation par le
CNFPT tout ça
s'impose à mon avis si on veut le
péréniser l'encadrer et l'inscrire
véritablement dans quelque chose chose
de sérieux alternativement une aide
spécifique pour être dédié aux
collectivités qui financ sur fond propre
les formations de leur propres agents au
cap petite enfance ou au BAFA ce sont
des propositions que nous faisons et qui
mérite je crois d'être regardé et d'être
regardé de près voilà les messages
essentiels vous les avez entendus il y
avait au démarrage plutôt disons
d'acceptation hein de de l'idée hein de
la réforme des des des temps scolaires
il y a eu un pourcentage non négligeable
d'ailleurs dès 2013 he des 40 % me dit
me souffle mon collaborateur David
constant Martini donc c'est pas c'est
c'est mieux que la moyenne je DIRIS
médiane nationale
euh il y a des efforts qui se sont
révélés au
moins au niveau que nous avions annoncé
qui semblait excessif aux yeux je dirais
pas du ministre parce qu'il est plus
politique mais de l'administration
centrale de son ministère les 150 €
c'était pas de la blague ils ont été
largement atteints en moyenne et on est
souvent arrivé à à
200 le on n'est pas au bout de nos
discussions alors ni avec le
gouvernement sur la pérénisation ni de
des CA d'allocation familiale je l'ai
expliqué pérenisation sur les taux
d'encadrement et puis les moyens finan
évidemment pour le faire la volonté
aussi c'est que tous ceux qui ont joué
le jeu et qui sont au fond à la fois une
force d'entraînement pour les autres qui
sont aussi une source d'évaluation pour
voir ce qui marche et ce qui marche pas
ne fasse pas les frais de l'opération ce
serait la double peine alors il faudrait
au contraire les récompenser parce
qu'ils ont été d'une certaine façon les
cobailes ils ont joué le jeu et il faut
pouvoir les aider et le seule façon fond
que tout le monde y soit et soit aidé
c'est qu'on pérénise tout ça très
sérieusement que le fond d'amorçage
devient un fond de pérénisation quit à
ce qu'il soit décroissant avec le temps
et qu'il y ait une négociation globale
avec les caises d'allocation familial
au-delà d'un accord national entre le
Premier ministre et la Caisse nationale
d'allocation
familiale merci monsieur le Président je
suis ravie que vous ayez mis l'accent
sur le fait que les les plus vertueux ne
soient pas sanctionnés je vous donner un
exemple tout simple de mère d'une toute
petite commune en ce qui me concerne
nous avons été vertueux parce que nous
avons il y a il y a une dizaine d'années
déjà mis en place le périscolaire nous
avions des
aides non négligeables de la CAF à ce
moment-là et beaucoup de communes
avaient décidé de ne pas faire et
finalement petit à petit
elles se sont mises à à développer à
organiser des périscolaires et on nous a
fait savoir la CAF écoutez voilà vous
êtes à plein régime et cetera ça sera
dégressif petit à petit parce qu'il nous
faut une enveloppe beaucoup plus
importante pour aider tous ceux qui
n'ont pas fait jusqu'à présent donc
merci de ce message monsieur le
Président j'espère que là vous serez
entendu madame le rapporteur
oui oui oui merci monsieur le
Président vous je pense que vous pouvez
être assuré à la fois de ce que vous
nous avez dit que ça soit bien inscrit
mais je vous dis même ça fait écho ça
fait écho par rapport à à d'autres
auditions que nous avons faites ça fait
écho par rapport à nous notre vécu et
donc il y a deux points particulier euh
nous avons déjà fait une audition de la
CAF nous en sommes nous en sommes restés
très
dubitatif sur
euh la capacité et la volonté à donc
nous allons continuer et et sans
dévoiler ce que seront des conclusions
de ce rapport euh nous pensons que il y
a une vraie difficulté d'autant plus
qu'alors peut-être que chez vous grande
villees ça ne se traduit pas comme ça
mais des petites villes que nous avions
auditionné tout à l'heure ou des très
petites nous font l'aveu que vu la
complexité elles renonce au dosiera au
dossier CAF et au 54 € qui viennent par
enfant en accompagnement la réforme des
rythmes
donc alors vous peut-être vous vous
hortez pas cela parce les grandes villes
ont une structure administrative capable
de
mais on a aussi cette cette
difficulté donc deux questions une
première par rapport au nombre de villes
que donc vous regroupez qui sont
adhérantes est-ce que vous avez alors
c'est vous nous avez dit le pourcentage
de celles qui sont passées en 2013
est-ce que vous en avez qui ont fait
savoir que non elles ne passerait pas en
2014 ou est-ce qu'elles sont toutes dans
une démarche de conr conuction pour
passer en
2014 la deuxème la deuxème
question vous nous avez donné bon un
prix qui va par par
enfant est-ce que par
rapport mais c'est j'ai conscience que
c'est difficile mais est-ce qu'on peut
avoir une vision en terme de pourcentage
par rapport au budget de fonctionnement
d'une ville c'est-à-dire le la la le
surcoupt des rythmes euh est-ce que euh
voilà ça se situe euh à plus de 1 % à
moins de 1 % par rapport à des chiffres
qu'on a aujourd'hui on on varie comme
cela et donc c'était pour euh savoir
peut-être même que vous l'avez pas là et
que vous pourriez euh nous le faire nous
le faire parvenir voilà donc c'était les
les deux et le troisème sur lequel je
pense nous travaillerons qui nous
apparaît
essentiel aussi c'est la
professionnalisation et sans doute une
piste avec le CNFPT comment monter des
formations professionnalisantes et qui
peuvent aussi réunir
différents statut d'intervenants mais
qui sont tous là dans le même projet
voilà merci merci Madame la rapporteur
j'espère que vous ne m'en voudrez pas je
vais tout de suite associer les deux
questions pour que monsieur le Président
puisse partir à l'heure madame blonda
égal donc madame duchenè monsieur Carles
madame blonda mais des questions courtes
très bien
courte je sais puisque je connais j'ai
travaillé avec vous tous combien la
ville de Grenoble avait un
projet très en pointe sur la petite
enfance est-ce que les rythmes scolaires
se sont
accrochés à cette
politique comment avez-vous lié les deux
si si c'est court hein je ne veux
surtout
pas merci madame duchè monsieur Carl oui
d'abord merci président de nous avoir
présenté la la situation des 48 villes
dont vous êtes le Président si elles
sont pas nombreuses en nombre elles
représente une bonne part de la
population et elles ont un effet
d'entraînement donc il y a à peu près 20
villes qui sont passées alors qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire pour convaincre les 28
autres de le faire et quels sont les
freins principaux que vous avez
rencontré et deuxème question concernant
le financement c'est vrai donc qu'il
faudra passer de la négociation entre
les le ministre et la et la knaf à une
contractualisation et comment on peut
mettre en place cette contractualisation
car vous avez dit qu'effectivement les
règles ne pouvaient pas être les mêmes
pour tout le monde et qu'il y avait pas
de loi universelle j'aurais souhaité
qu'on ait pu vous auditer hier avant le
débat que nous avons
eu merci Monsieur monsieur monsieur
Carle pour ces questions madame
blonda
euh je crois que effectivement hier nous
avons dit aussi qu'il y avait une
richesse territoriale et qu'il y avait
une expérience à tirer au niveau des
territoires donc adapter le National au
local j'aurais voulu vous demander
est-ce que vous avez mis en place dans
votre ville un une sorte de comité de
suivi ou d'évaluation de du de cette
mise en œuvre des des rythmes et quels
ont été pour vous les l'aide apporté ou
ou pas d'aide apporté par les services
de la
daen merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président
desto bien merci infiniment pour pour
ces questions et et leur intérêt je
rappelle donc ces 48 villes de plus de
100000 habitants euh je vais sur surtout
parler de Séville centre parce que c'est
un petit peu plus difficile à prendre
une de faire une appréciation sur
évidemment l'ensemble des
intercommunalités vous prenez la la
ville de Grenoble vous avez une
trentaine d'autres villes mais c'est de
de communes c'est très difficile
d'apprécier là davantage les
choses j'ai dit 40 % sont partis hein
dans le rythme les rythmes scolaires dè
l'année 2013 à ma connaiss il en avait
trois mais c'était Marseille qui a
décidé de partir en 2014 hier annoncé
donc il ne resterait plus que Nice et
Cannes qui ne n'accepterait pas de
partir en 2014 donc je dois dire que
c'est je pas
dire plein pot mais en tout cas c'est
une très très très très grande majorité
de villes qui sur les de années hein
2013 2014 va se lancer dans cette
réforme des rythmes scolair et je
remercie d'ailleurs
le le mon collègue Carl qui a bon
accepté de dire que nous étions
effectivement force d'entraînement nous
les grandes villes et que c'était bien
le souhait que nous avions j'ai pas j'ai
fait état he des des difficultés j'ai
fait état des souhaits que nous avions
ou des revendications souvent fortes
hein avec le gouvernement mais sur
l'objectif hein ça confirme si vous
voulez les la volonté de de poursuivre
ses ses objectifs
la ville de Grenoble puisque la question
m'a été posée sur Grenoble a fait des
efforts je crois importants puisque
c'estes
3 200000 € qui donc sont consacrés en
année
pleine en plus de ce que nous faisons
évidemment pour le le la petite enfance
et les scolair hein pour l'adaptation à
ces rythmes
scolaires si représente pratiquement un
peu plus d'un % du budget de
fonctionnement de la ville donc ça n'est
pas ça n'est pas marginal je dois le
dire et ça se rajoute puisque c'est une
autre question qui m' été posé ça se
substitue pas ça se rajoute à tout ce
qui a été fait en matière de de petite
enfance alors je suis toujours un peu
gêné parce que comme on est je crois
matière petite enfance les numéros en
France donc c'est toujours un petit peu
gênant de de parler de soi hein puisque
vous savez on a 30 % de la population
qui est prise hein dans notre t nos
équipements de de de petit enfant avant
même le la prise en charge le cycle
scolaire avec une volonté de prendre
notamment toutes les familles les les
les les plus déshéritées les plus
pauvres les plus fragiles hein de de la
population nous avons beaucoup
expérimenté aussi notamment à travers ce
qui est de plus en plus connu le concept
du parler bambin hein où on prend des
jeunes de de 18 à 36 mois on les
accompagne avec des des pédagogues des
psych ologue et on s'aperçoit que à à
talent égal hein quelle que soit
l'origine y compris pour des jeunes
enfants qui sont d'origine étrangère qui
parlaient même pas un mot de français
quand ils sont arrivés et bien le niveau
de enfin les capacités langagière hein
au bout de ces 36 mois c'est-à-dire à 3
ans au quand on va démarrer le le le
parcours scolaire elle même et ça c'est
quand même c'est formidable le principal
des inégalités dans la vie est inégalité
à la source et on sait que si on arrive
effectivement à cette prise en charge
très tôt et bien on améliore
considérablement considérablement les
chances du jeune ensuite dans dans son
propre parcours scolaire donc c'est pas
en substitution c'est en plus donc
évidemment ça se cumule et c'est des
efforts qui sont qui ne sont pas
négligeables pour répondre à à mon
collègue et ami Carles qu'est-ce qu'il
faut bah il faut du temps temps
qu'est-ce qu'il faut il faut de l'argent
qu'est-ce qu'il faut du personnel
qualifié c'est-à-dire
que pour y arriver et c'est pour ça
qu'on ne pouvait pas partout le faire
immédiatement il y avait pas ces trois
disponibilités d'un seul coup hein qui
faisait que à moins de de dire on le
fait on le fait on le
fait dans la fuite en avant B beaucoup
je vois par exemple à Lille où ils
étaient complètement décidé à faire la
réforme de ryme scolaire euh B la mère
Martin auri a décidé non c'est pas
possible parce que je n'ai pas dès la
rentrée scolaire de de 2013 hein
l'ensemble des moyens pas simplement
financiers bien sûr une ville qui est
quand même pas très riche et puis bon
vous savez les charges sociales sont
quand même très fortes mais ell n'avait
pas les possibilités d'avoir les
ressources notamment humaines pour
pouvoir être sûr de de gagner la partie
dès la la rentrée 2013 donc ça je crois
que ça rejoint d'ailleurs ce que je
disais tout à l'heure parce que même là
où on avait peut-être un petit peu
d'avance hein on s'aperçoit qu'une
nécessité absolue d'accompagnement en
terme de qualification de formation et
donc c'est au fond ce qu'il va falloir
rajouter à l'intérieur de CNFPT pour
justement accompagner le le personnel
communal l'éducation
nationale
difficile d'avoir une réponse unique
partout en
France comment vous
dire c'est c'est une des difficultés
qu'on rencontre d'ailleurs en politique
de la ville comme un peu un peu
partout bah il y a la justice et
l'éducation nationale qui qui échappe à
l'interministérialité c'est comme ça le
le préfet n'a pas barre ni sur un
procureur de la République ni sur dazen
donc on est là dans une situation un peu
particulière à partir du moment où
voulez faire on vaut faire des
politiques coordonnées ben on a souvent
un petit peu des difficultés parce que
c'est des gens
qui considèrent qu'ils ont une autorité
hein plus qu'une représentation
administrative à coordonnée et à partir
de ce moment-là il est plus difficile
d'avoir des politiques qui soit
coordonné alors là vous avez par exemple
en petit la ville en sécurité procureur
actif sur le terrain ça marche très très
bien là où il considère au contraire qui
qui qui nont pas de d'ordre de conseil
d'avis à donner qu'ils ont pas assez de
moyens ben ils se retirent et dans
l'éducation nationale et ben vous savez
aussi il y a des établissements où on
joue le jeu il y en a d'autres où on
joue moins le jeu et c'est pas toujours
facile d'avoir une réponse en tout cas
une réponse unique euh voilà je je veux
pas être langue de bois donc je préfère
répondre comme ça alors euh ça se passe
bien à Grenoble parce que je voudrais
pas que comme le le rapport va être
public hein que j'ai des ennuis avec
Madame lesco inspectrice académique
maintenant donc directrice des services
académiques de de ler qui qui fait un
travail absolument remarquable mais euh
c'est plus ou moins remarquable selon
les établissements scolaires et c'est
plus ou moins remarquable selon les
académies il faut parler clairement et
donc bon ben voilà ce que je veux dire
c'est pas parole d'évangile universelle
c'est évidemment très très variable hein
ce selon les endroits ben voilà je me
permets de le dire c'est une des
difficultés d'ailleurs hein je l'avais
dit à Vincent payon bon tous les
ministres de l'éducation national sont
heureux d'avoir leur propre
administration avec leur propre recteur
tout ça c'est bien gentil mais quand on
veut véritablement faire des politiques
coordonnées efficaces qui nécessitent
justement ce travail partenar al ça rend
les choses un tout petit peu plus
difficiles voilà pour ces auditions qui
ont été menées par la mission commune
d'information sur les rythmes scolaires
ici au Sénat mission commune
d'information qui a d'ailleurs abouti un
rapport assez compliqué puisque la
présidente et la rapporteur n'ont
finalement pas réussi à se mettre
d'accord sur leur conclusion alors même
que sur l'ensemble de l'année les
travaux avaient été menés de façon assez
sereine mais vous avez pu l'entendre il
y a aussi une certaine inquiétude de la
part de nombreux élus locaux sur le
financement de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires c'est un sujet épineux à
l'approche des élections sénatoriales du
28 septembre prochain élections
sénatoriales qui verront le
renouvellement de la moitié de la haute
assemblée qui verront donc ces élus
locaux se rendre aux urnes et peut-être
donc sanctionner la gauche vous pouvez
toujours voir et revoir toutes les
auditions sur notre site sur
publsenab.fr très bonne fin de journée
sur les chaînes
parlementaires